[MUSIC PLAYING]
HADLEY WICKHAM: So today
I am excited to talk
about the third
edition of testthat.
So I'm going to start by talking
a little bit about like what
do I mean by that.
You certainly all know what
a version of a package is
but what do I mean by this being
the third edition of testthat.
And I'm going to talk through
kind of three big new features
in this version,
in this edition,
see how testthat now displays
differences much more clearly
using the Waldo package.
We'll talk about a new type of
testing, new type of testing
to test that snapshot tests.
Very briefly talk about testing
in parallel or multi process
testing.
And then finally, I'm going
to give you a real quick goody
bag of a bunch of
little small stuff
that will hopefully make your
life a little bit easier when
using testthat.
So the big news
with this release
of testthat this upcoming
release of testthat 3.0
is we're going to introduce
the idea of this third edition.
And I should say
anything you're going
to hear about today
is also explained
in more detail in vignettes
on the testthat website.
If you want to learn
more about anything
I say today feel free to take
a look at those vignettes
and if they don't
explain, they don't
help you understand
what's going on
please file an issue so
they can [INAUDIBLE] better.
So the basic idea
of the edition is
that we want to make
breaking changes to testthat.
Testthat is like 10
years old or something
and there's a bunch of things in
the package that we now regret.
But testthat is kind of a
victim of its own popularity.
There's something like 4,000
or 5,000 packages on CRAN
that use test that
and many of them
are not actively developed.
So there's no way
we can change test
that without breaking
a bunch of packages,
and many of these packages since
they wouldn't be maintained
people would just end up off
CRAN because people wouldn't
have the energy to fix them.
So the idea of an
edition is that this
is something you have to
deliberately opt into.
So if you want to use
many of the new features
or all of the new
features of testthat
that I talk about today you
have to deliberately choose
to use the third
edition of testthat.
And to sort of do
that you basically
have to add a line description
file, config/testthat/edition.
So if you don't do
this, you'll continue
to use the second edition,
that's the existing
behavior of testthat.
If you do change this you'll
get a bunch of new features
and a bunch of things
which I'll explain shortly
which have gone away.
So the kind of idea is that
it should take hopefully
less than 30 minutes
to convert a package
to use the third edition.
It's a little bit of work,
hopefully, not too much work.
But it just
generally gets you up
to date with all about
current best practices.
And I should say
this kind of idea
or this edition idea
is successful it's
something we're
likely to try out
in other packages as a way
of allowing existing code
to continue working while
giving you the choice to opt
into a new simplified edition.
So editions will always be
coupled with a major version,
so that means testthat 2 and
everything else before it
counts as the second edition.
Testthat 3.0 can use the second
edition as the default behavior
or you can opt into
using the third edition
and if one day many probably
multiple years down the line
we decide to introduce
a fourth edition then
that would be tied
to testthat 4.0.
So what's going away
in the third edition.
These are the
things that are most
likely to lead you to change
a test to other context.
Function is going
away, we've kind
of being moving away from this
for quite some time in favor
of just using the
name of the text file.
There's no need to kind of
duplicate the information
in the test file in
another function which
you have to remember to update
if you ever loose your test
files.
We've also been lately in
devtools and users building
kind of a strong coupling
between files in our directory
and files in the
test directories
so that there is a
kind of a one to one
correspondence which gives
you a bunch of handy keyboard
shortcuts and development tools.
The very old expect that
function is going away.
This was the kind of first API.
The first excessively
clever API that testthat
use with every test
kind of had the flavor.
You could read it like a
sentence like testthat law
is true and I pretty
quickly decided
that that was excessively
clever not very good,
and so we're finally
deprecating that for good.
Expect is we are deprecating in
favor of expect is three class,
expect is four class
and expect type of just
to be more precise
about what exactly
you're trying to express.
Expect equivalent, I'll talk
about a little bit later.
But we're basically that's
just giving an argument
to expect equal or
expect identical.
Some of the mocking
functions going away
in favor of more
feature packages.
And then finally, we are
moving away from setup
and tear down in favor
of test fixtures,
which I'm not going
to talk about today.
But there's a whole
vignette about them
if you want to learn more.
And hopefully, that's kind
of all, I need to say,
just these are the functions
that are going away.
Like if you really, really
believe any of these functions
are important,
like now's the time
to speak up and say you
want to keep these otherwise
when you switch the second--
search of the third edition
re-run on your tests
you'll get deprecation
messages telling you what
to replace instructions with.
So that's kind of the
stuff that's going away now
I want to focus on
the cool new features.
And I think the feature you're
most likely to encounter
and the most likely to give
you pleasure in your life
is the comparisons with
expect equal and expect
identical with test
failures with expect equal
and expect identical and now
much easier to understand.
So previously expect
equal uses the base
all dot equal function.
This was never
really what all dot
equal was intended for but
it kind of did an OK job.
But there's a few cases
where it just doesn't
give very useful output.
And so here I am
comparing empty cars
without the first
column to empty cars
but the full data set.
And you'll notice I
get a lot of output.
Well it tells me that there's
10 string mismatches which
is in the names that
doesn't really help me.
It tells me there's
a length mismatch
and then it gives me a bunch
of mean relative differences.
So this certainly tells me
that there's a difference
but it doesn't kind
of concisely crisply
point me to the fact there's
a column missing in this data
frame.
So now we use Waldo.
So to use this--
I'm just going to use this
function called local addition.
This is not something
you generally
need to use in your
tests because you'll
convert a whole package
to use the third edition
but we provide this
local edition function
for writing stuff like
this, for writing vignettes.
So you can explain
about this new edition.
This just temporarily sets the
edition to the third edition.
So now we use the third
edition and now this
is the new Waldo output.
So the kind of the
first principle
is that Waldo is going
to give you the most
important differences
first and in this case
I think the most
important difference is
that the length are different.
And then it tells us
what the names are,
how the names have changed
lining up the old names--
lining up sorry, the actual
names or the expected names
and then it uses
color to highlight
the fact that in the expected is
another column called the mpg.
And then finally, down here,
we get an exact description.
Well, the names are
different but the value
are also different.
The actual that's-- and as I
read this that is clearly not
the case because it's absent
from the expected so I think
I've messed up the labels here.
So I'll have to fix
these they should
say expected mpg is
absent and this should
say actual mpg is a double.
So that just allows you once I
fix those labels to precisely
see what the difference is.
So here I have switched
to use the third edition,
Waldo then shows the most
important differences first.
It uses color to help
highlight differences.
Oh, and always use the names
of things where possible just
because that makes it
easier to understand exactly
where the differences lie.
So another little
example here I had
a factor versus an ordered
factor with one extra level.
When you look at the
expect equal output
from the second edition you'll
see like it kind of tells you
that they're different
but it's hard
because it doesn't
include the values to know
exactly what's changed.
When we switch to
the third edition
now we can say there's a new
element of the class that
gets ordered and there's a new
element of the levels, which
is d and hopefully this will
make it much, much easier
to see exactly what's going on.
And certainly in my own--
this is the number one reason
I've been converting packages
to use the third edition to
test that just because it
makes things so
much easier to study
when something's gone wrong.
So if you want to
learn more about Waldo,
you can go to the
Waldo websites which
shows a bunch of
kind of examples,
shows some of the principles.
A lot of the differences
of the values
are powered by this really
nice package called diffobj
by Brodie Gaslam, which uses
the same algorithm as the diff
utility on Linux which just
makes it really easy to narrow
and exactly what has changed
between two packages.
This change also
makes it now possible
to be precise about what's
the difference between expect
equal, expect
identical, and expect
equivalent, which are always
a little vague in the past.
Now all of these functions
are equivalent to expect
identical but with some
extra arguments here.
So if you use
expect equal that's
equivalent to expect
identical, except that it
ignores small floating
point differences.
Or if you use expect equivalent,
which is now deprecated
it's just the same
as using expect equal
or expect equivalent with
ignore attribute equals true.
That's the only thing that
expect equivalent does
is it just ignores attributes.
Now we're going to make
that precise in the function
argument.
And then any other
arguments and identical
expect equal are passed onto
Waldo compare which gives you
the ability to fine tune
your comparisons as needed.
Now, this is such
a great idea you
might wonder why kind I
work with the second edition
as well.
Well, unfortunately when
I implemented expect equal
it turns out that I made
a rather silly mistake
when implementing the
tolerance comparison.
So depending on exactly which
code path, it goes down,
it computes the tolerance
in slightly different ways.
One where it always uses
the absolute tolerance,
and one where it uses absolute
or relative tolerance.
There's basically no way,
I did a few experiments,
there's no way
regardless of which one
I pick it causes like hundreds
of print packages to break,
so that's the main
reason that this
has to be in the third edition.
But there's a few
other small things
particularly if you are testing
code in a modeling package,
all dot equal
which used to power
expect equal ignores
environments of formulas
and models--
sorry, formulas and functions.
Waldo does not but it
provides a couple of arguments
to allow you to override
that if you need to.
And there's a few other small
things around like [INAUDIBLE]..
So I think the behavior of
Waldo is generally better,
it's a little bit
stricter and when it fails
it'll give you clearer results.
But we can't just turn
it on for everyone
because it would break
a bunch of tests.
So you're going to have to
deliberately opt in to it.
So that's Waldo I think that's
like kind of number 1 feature.
Likes again I have
found it so useful
when debugging tests myself
to have that much much, much
clearer display.
The next big feature I want to
talk about is snapshot testing.
Again, this comes
with a vignette,
so if you want to
learn more about it,
you can read the vignette.
If the vignette
doesn't make sense,
please file an issue so
we can make it better.
But the basic idea is this
is a new type of testing.
So normally in unit tests you
describe the expected output
using codes.
And in the vast
majority of cases
this is a really,
really good idea
because it allows
you to describe
what you expect
and in some scenes
the tests help
documents, because it
tests the code and code is
a means of communication.
They kind of help describe
the expected behavior
of the functions as well.
But sometimes describing
the expected output
is just like really annoying.
Like if it contains a bunch
of spacial characters,
like quotes or back slashes you
have to spend a bunch of time
like carefully escaping them.
And then when
something goes wrong,
it's hard to see exactly,
like you've got to escape
and when you can it's just a
pain or maybe it's very large.
Like maybe you want to
check an entire HTML
page or multiple paragraphs
of text as you expect
or maybe it's not even
something that you can usually
describe with text it's an
image or something else.
So the idea of a snapshot
a golden tests which idea
used in other programming
languages, and other testing
packages, and test
that inspiration
draws primarily from Jest
which is a JavaScript testing
package that Joe Chang shared
his experiences with me a bunch
and persuaded me that this
is something really useful.
But so the snapshot
test the key idea
is that instead of recording
the results in line
and the test itself that's
stored in a separate file.
And test that provides a bunch
of tools for looking after that
for managing that file.
It created automatically
the first time you run it
and then it gives you tools
to update it when you decide
it really has good change.
And if you've used verify
output or expect known output
which we've never
really advertised
because we've never really
been particularly happy with
and the snapshot tests basically
supersede those functions.
So what does a snapshot
test looks like.
So here I'm just
going to give you
a quick simulation
in the presentation
and I'll show you what this
looks like in a real package.
So here I've got
two files foo dot
R I've just got this very
silly and simple function which
has a mistake in it,
which you can see,
which we'll fix shortly.
And then I've got a test.
So I run foo, I expect
it as a character vector,
and then I'm going to use this
new expectation expect snapshot
output.
And this doesn't have like
what the expected value is
because it's going
to save to disc.
So the first time I run this
it's going to say warning
create snapshot reference
and it creates a new file,
and I forgot to put the create
directory in here inside the--
inside the test dot directory is
going to create a new directory
called snaps, _snaps, and inside
that it's going to have a file
called foo dot md.
So R file is called foo dot R.
Our test file is called test
dash food dot R. And
then our snapshot
for that, the snapshot file is
going to be called foo dot md.
So all of the users names have
a strong naming conventions
so you can easily
find which snapshot
corresponds to which test, which
corresponds to which R file.
So what does that
snapshot contain?
Well, it's a markdown file.
Kind of explain
the syntax shortly.
But we use a heading to
indicate that this is the test
and then it's going to put
the output of that test
directly in that file.
So now if I run it again,
if I run that test again,
the test is going to work
because nothing's changed.
And so the test will pass.
If I change it to fix that
typo, I run the test again,
I'm going to get an era saying
that the previous value was
something complicated
and the new value
is something complicated.
Now, the downside
of snapshot tests
is that there's no way
to know what is correct.
So you as a human now have
to step in and intervene.
So if this is
correct if you really
did mean to make this change
you can run snapshot accept
and that will accept the change.
And the way that this
works is that when
you have this value, when
something has changed
there will be a
new markdown file
which contains the new
value if you accept it then
it will replace that with
the [INAUDIBLE] value.
So let's go to the big picture.
So let's just dive into
that for a slightly more
realistic example.
Start with a simple one.
So I have this package,
I have the same test
which I copied before and
I'm going to run this test.
And I'm going to run this test
by pressing command t which
is a shortcut but div tools.
Test file.
So this keyboard shortcut takes
advantage of that convention
that if you've got a
file called foo dot R
the corresponding test
will be test dot foo.
And so this says I've
added a new snapshot.
This is the value of
that snapshot I can
look at it as a markdown file.
Again, which I'll
explain shortly.
And then if I run
that test again
you'll see that all
the test have passed.
The other thing if you've used
dev tool test file before--
which I'll talk
about briefly later--
is there's now a slightly
different display,
slightly more compact display
that hopefully make it easier
to run tests for single
file interactively.
So if I change this, I'm
going to correct that typo.
I'm going to test
again and now the test
files because a
snapshot has changed.
So it shows you
the current value,
which is something
complicated and it
shows you the previous value
which is something complicated.
Now, if this is a
deliberate change
you can run snapshot accept.
If this wasn't a deliberate
change or that was just a typo,
I can fix it and rerun and
all my tests pass again.
So if you've ever
used verify output.
This is a little bit different
because verify output
automatically update with a kind
of true known value [INAUDIBLE]
forced you to use it
with get, basically.
So I'm going to fix
this, the test file.
You can see now in my
snaps directory I got foo.
That's the foo dot md
that's the previous value,
and I've got foo dot new dot
md, which is the new value.
So I look at this I decide that
it actually correct and then I
can just copy and paste this.
And now foo dot md
is the correct result
and I can test that again.
OK.
So let's look at a slightly
more complicated example.
So this is a bullets
function and it's basically
used to create HTML bullets.
So it looks like this.
And this is like
a little annoying
to test because if you're going
to put this in a test you'd
have to escape all of these
new lines and kind of carefully
manage all the white
space, it's just a pain.
So to test this code
it's a little easy
to use a snapshot test.
So I can run this
test and now here
is a test snapshot file with
multiple expectations in it.
The first one I am
just using a bullet
with a single bullet and the
second also is a single bullet
and also is the ID.
So when later I want to
change this bullets function,
maybe I've decided actually
I don't want this indent.
Let's get rid of that.
I rerun the test.
Again, the changes use Waldo
to highlight what's changed.
So it's a little bit
hard to see this,
but this is the thing that's
the same it's in gray.
What's changed while
we can see there
is now no space where
there was before.
So I look at this I decide,
yep, that's a deliberate change,
and then I run snapshot
accept bullets.
Bullets to update that snapshot.
And that basically is snapshot.
Of course, there's
more documentation.
And I think it'll take a little
while to get you hit around it
or I've shown you expect
snapshot output here,
just also expect snapshot, which
as Waldo's printed output also
captures messages,
warnings, errors.
There's also expect
snapshot error
if you want to
capture specifically
just error messages
and then we've
got expect snapshot value
which captures return value.
This is a little bit different.
This is if you for
example, wanted
to test the output from
a complicated function,
you just want to
make sure it doesn't
change without warning you
can use expect snapshot value.
And then again,
of course, there's
the vignette which
you can look at.
I guess I can't show
it because I did not--
I've installed the development
vision of the package which
doesn't have the vignettes
but you can go to the website.
Actually, let's just
go to the website.
And then we can see
all these vignettes.
Here's one on
snapshot testing just
giving you a little bit more
detail about what I just
talked about.
The only other thing
to mention is just
what are these files look like
why are they markdown files?
Well, if you're
writing this package
as a collaborative
project and you're
using GitHub or some other
tool where you do code review
it's really important that these
snapshots be human readable.
Because when someone
goes to review your code
they need to go look at
the snapshot and say,
is this a reasonable
change or not.
So they use markdown.
Each file again there's one
snapshot file for the test file
which only corresponds to
a file in the directory.
There's a heading
for the test name.
And then if you have multiple
snapshot expectations
of a single test
that is separated
by the horizontal
roll and three dashes.
One thing that I'm working on
at the moment and with some help
from Joshua Canst
is a shiny app that
will help you review
all of these differences
and accept them or reject them
by clicking buttons rather
than typing stuff
at the console,
and the other big part of that
is providing tools for doing
image snapshots as well.
So this is something that
we've implemented in two places
and shiny test, which is
used for testing shiny,
and vdiffr, which is
used for testing ggplot2.
The idea is they're going
to pull out the common code,
centralize and test
that and invest
a bunch in this
whole snapshot idea.
So you've got a
really nice workflow
if you do need to do image test.
Image tests are
complicated because they
can change for all sorts of
reasons unrelated to your code
but sometimes
they're all you have
and they are really
important part
of testing both shiny
itself and ggplot2 itself.
So that's snapshot tests.
Main idea of snapshot test is
compared to regular unit tests
which have the expected
results in the test file,
snapshot tests store the
expected results in another
file, which makes them suitable
for testing large output,
output with quote marks and
backslash in it and for testing
things that you simply cannot
describe with text like images.
Next, I wanted to talk
briefly about parallel tests.
This is still a work in
progress by [INAUDIBLE]..
And again, you have to
activate this specifically
for your package.
Again, by putting another
line in your description
config testthat parallel true.
But the payoff for
this is pretty big.
It's going to run your
tests on multiple processes.
So if you have
long running tests
this is going to make
a big improvement
to the total running
time of your tests.
Now but the downside
is like there's
a little bit of
overhead associated
with that starting up multiple R
packages, multiple R processes.
Loading all the code in those.
So there's a little
bit of overheads.
So if your test are very fast
like if you tests all run in
under a second it's probably
not going to have a huge impact.
But if you've got tests that
take five or 10 seconds.
The whole test
like takes minutes
then this should hopefully have
a really big positive impact
on your work flow.
There are some downsides as well
as this big upside of speed,
tests will now
kind of effectively
run in stochastic
order because you'll
have like four processes.
And each process takes kind
of the next test in the queue.
And so depending on exactly
how long each test takes
to run like, the test might
get run in a different order.
And this basically
means if you have
any dependency
between your tests
which is relatively
easy to introduce,
because normally they will
run in alphabetical order.
If it has any dependency
between test files
you will get like random
test failures that
occur sometimes but don't
occur other times depending
on exactly which order
the tests are run in.
In other words, this is like a
dependency debugging nightmare.
So we're still
thinking about tools
to ensure that if
that happens to you
we've got some debugging
mode you can switch on
to get more insight.
And also if you have used like
global set up or tear down.
For example, like you set up
a database or some CSV file
for all of your
tests, you're going
to need to think that through
in a little bit more detail
because those set up and
tear out files are now
run by multiple processors.
So there's going to be a
little bit of work to convert
your test to use parallel.
We're still working on this.
There's a vignette if you
want to learn more and want
to try it out.
But we're hopeful that this
will make a big impact If you've
got long running tests.
So I've talked about this
idea of a third edition.
This is a special
mode, you'll have
to switch on if you want to
use all the latest and greatest
testthat features.
We've talked about Waldo, which
makes comparisons or test makes
like test failures from expect
equal and prints much, much
easier.
We talked about
snap chatting tests.
We talked about running
tests in parallel.
Now, I just want
to show you kind
of a bunch of little features
that I think are kind of cool.
So in the course of working
on testthat, for this release,
made a bunch of improvements
to the reporters.
The reporters are the things
that actually go and generate
the results.
So when I press test this
is done by a reporter.
If I press command ship t
to run all of the tests.
These are different reporters.
One reporter that you never
normally use is called stop
or-- you don't normally
call it explicitly
but it's called stop reporter.
That's the test that's run--
sorry.
That's the report that's
run when you run a test
interactively so here I'm
just running a test which
is not working for
probably reasons that I
need to look into.
But if I create--
up here I have another example.
Over here.
If I run this test, this
is the stop reporter.
Now, it clearly tells you that
your test passed and gives you
some emoji.
If your test does not pass it
nicely displays the failures.
And it also displays
any warnings
and really conveniently
it also displays
the back trace for the warning.
So if you've got warnings
on any of your tests
now they get a full back trace
so you can figure out exactly
where that warning came from.
One of my kind of
pet peeves is--
how do we do this--
is this I have--
I have partial matching
warnings turned on.
And if this occurs
like somewhere deep,
inside a function,
inside another function it's
really hard to track down now
on your test you
get this nice back
trace so you can figure
out exactly what function,
what sequence of functions
leads to that problem.
So that's the stop
reporter which
is used in debugging so now use
color, use emoji, and generally
it gives you more
information about problems
when you're interactively
running tests.
I showed you earlier that
compact progress reporter that
is the single line here, which
gives you kind of running this
is a little bit [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit fast.
So you can do the
slow test [INAUDIBLE]
So just having a
little loop here,
we're just going to
do an expectation
and then sleep for a little bit.
So you can see it like count's
up now it's a little slower.
So you get like a
running progress
bar in some sense
on all the tests
that are running so you know
exactly what's going on.
I've made a regular
reporter which
you see most often
when you're running
all the tests in your package.
The biggest thing is I've
added a bunch of new praise.
That uses more emoji because
I think emoji are fun.
This random praise is going to
veer a little bit into dad joke
territory.
But hopefully, that's just
something, a fun little feature
of testthat that
keeps you motivated
and keeps you going when your
tests aren't working well.
Finally, the last reporter
is the check reporter
that's run inside of
our commands check.
Now it reports all
of the problems.
Sort of also reports
warnings and skipped tests.
It tells you all of
your skipped tests
by type which is really useful
with checking that you haven't
accidentally skipped tests
that you meant to run
and it also creates a IDS
file with a machine readable
list of all of the tests.
That's probably not something
you want to use directly
but it is something that we will
start to build into our tooling
so that things like
get out of actions
can give you nice displays
of good tests and so on.
We've also made a few
changes to the way
that the condition
functions work.
So here I have a function
that calls warn and message.
And now if a condition like a
message of warning or an error
is not explicitly caught
by your expectation
it will continue to bubble up.
So if I run this
line [INAUDIBLE]
if I run this line this
expectation passes,
it does find a
warning called high
but the message called
Bye still bubbles up.
Or if I say I expect
a message called Bye
I'll see a warning called high.
So if I want to
capture both of them
I need to use expect the message
and expect warning together.
This hopefully will
give you better control
over exactly what's going on.
It's going to cause a few
more warnings in your tests.
These won't cause your package
to fail our commands check
but they will require
a little bit of work
to make sure that
those tests are
as you expect if you want to
just ignore them you can still
rather than using
expectations and you can just
switch to the base functions
suppress messages and suppress
warnings if you don't
care about them.
Now, you might notice here that
we've got expectations next
to the side of expectations
and you might kind of naturally
think well, why can't I
use the pipe for that,
unfortunately you
cannot currently do that
because the pipe eagerly
evaluates everything.
So if I do this you
get a Bye, and a high,
and then this fails
because this is
called before this is called.
We will start to announce
a new work in magrittr that
will make this work and
hopefully make magrittr
a little more compatible
with the native pipe that
is unlikely to appear in the
next version of testthat.
So that's-- and that also means
if you're one of the 10 people
in the world who used the all
the arguments-- expect warning,
expect message--
that's now deprecated.
You're going to take a
slightly different approach.
But we're pretty
confident that's
going to be a much
nicer API overall
and shouldn't change
existing behavior too much.
And the last thing is if
you've ever used expect error
and it gives you
this message to set
the class we no
longer encourage you
to do that it kind of
fixed one type of test
fidelity basically, the cost of
increasing-- just introducing
a different type
of fidelity and so
now you're better off just using
expects snapshot error if you
want to check that a specific
error occurs because that just
gives you a bunch
of nice features
for managing the
change over time.
Just about to wrap
up, which is great.
So there's plenty of
time for questions.
So what have I
talked about today?
First, testthat 3.0
is coming out soon.
I should say we probably
start the release process
in about a month, which
means that's at least
two months before it's on CRAN.
So it would really be great
if you would try it out
and this is the right time to
let us know if this is causing
you pain so we can fix it
before release plenty of time
to do that.
So the third edition is going
to be a part of testthat 3.0
which will be on CRAN and
released as soon as possible
is probably two amounts.
It's likely to be
longer than that.
The third addition, you will
have to deliberately opt
into that gives you a
bunch of new features
at the cost of doing
a little bit of work
to clean up old APIs.
The new edition uses
Waldo to make comparisons
which will hopefully
make the test
failures much easier to debug.
It provides snapshot tests which
are alternative form of testing
where the expected results
are stored on separate files
rather than in line
and code and then
the testthat provides
some functions
to help manage these files so
that you can accept changes
when you have made
them deliberately
or revert changes when you've
made them accidentally.
Testthat 3.0 will also introduce
parallel testing, which again
will be a little bit
of set up work just
to make sure your global
setup and tear down works
appropriately and
don't accidentally
have any dependencies
between your tests
but the payoff
will be if you have
slow tests they should run
much, much faster because they
run in parallel.
And then finally I showed
you a bunch of goodies.
Many of them featuring
emoji that will hopefully
make your day to day life using
testthat a little bit more fun.
So if you do want
to try it out today
you need to get the
development version of testthat
and the development
vision of dev tools.
And then in your
package, if this
is a package that uses
continuous integration
or similar you need to
add testthat to remotes
and you need to accept the
addition to the third edition
to take advantage of all the
latest and greatest features.
That was a lot of
content in 40 minutes.
Again, hopefully, if you
didn't take in everything
I was saying there's plenty
of additional material
and all of the
vignettes, and if you
don't find those
understandable please
let me know so we
can make them better.
Thank you.
And now hopefully,
Jenny, you will
have some questions for me?
JENNY: Yeah.
So the first big one
is, I think people
want to hear more about why
you're doing a third edition.
So why not create an entirely
new package, the same way
that plyr led to dplyr, or
why not create testthat three.
Or why can you not do this
through semantic versioning
of the existing package?
HADLEY WICKHAM: OK, so
the first question is,
why not a new package?
And that was something
I considered.
But like 90% of the code
between the second edition
and the third
edition are the same.
The biggest difference
with the third edition
is it just takes stuff away from
you, stuff that we now regret.
So if we created a
new package, we'd
have two packages that have
like 90% overlap in the code,
and whenever there
was a bug we'd
have to remember to fix
them in both packages.
So I think for this case,
most of the stuff is the same,
we're just trying to get
rid of some new things.
I think creating a new
package would be overkill.
The question about
semantic visioning
is something that, yes, that
does use semantic versioning,
this is a major vision of
testthat three point 0.
But that actually doesn't
really help in the R community,
because you only have a single
version of a package installed
on your computer.
In a library you can
kind of work around that,
but it's a little fiddly.
And if a package is
on CRAN they always
use the latest version
of the package on CRAN.
So if I just released
testthat three point 0,
with all of these
new features on it,
something like
500 packages would
break on CRAN, because
they would automatically
use the version of
testthat that on CRAN.
So I think that
that's why we want
to make a little bit of
friction so that you have
to deliberately choose
to use this new testing,
use these new
conventions, basically
stop using old stuff that
you should have stopped using
a while ago without
duplicating a bunch of code
that we didn't have to
maintain in two places.
JENNY: OK, so now I have
a series of questions,
and the list is growing
longer, that are smaller,
and we'll just work
through as many as we can.
So this first one is, have you
tested whether snapshotting
plays nice with things like
cover or the good practice
package?
Does this third edition work
have any effect on shinytest?
So talking about how this
works with other packages.
HADLEY WICKHAM: Yeah,
so snapshot testing
is just testing, it just
works exactly the way
you'd expect with cover.
I don't know that much
about good practice.
I would think it
would not, I don't
think it would cause
problems for good practice.
shinytest-- it's not
clear precisely how this
will play out.
I've been having bigger
discussions with the shiny team
about how testing
shiny should work,
because my vision
for testing shiny
is quite different from their
vision of testing shiny apps.
So we're just
working towards that.
I think, in an ideal
world, eventually
shiny tests would use more
of this new snapshotting
infrastructure that
testthat provides.
But there's some
other big changes
that have to happen
to shinytest,
so it's hard to say today
whether that shinytest will
eventually integrate
this better or there
will be a new package
that's a successor
to shinytest that
uses some other stuff
and is more focused on
snapshot testing than testthat.
If you want to see my
take on testing shiny,
I'm working on this
chapter at the moment.
If you follow the
shiny test repo,
you'll notice that
I've recently triaged
like 100 and something issues.
So I'm thinking
about this a lot,
I'm starting to work on it.
I'm thinking about the test.
I don't exactly know
what the answer is,
but you can see
my latest thinking
in this package and this
chapter of mastering
shiny which will get
updated pretty rapidly
in the next week or two.
JENNY: All right, the next
one is, do test snapshots
need to be included in
the package or could
you exclude them
if they're large
and then developers can recreate
them from a stable version?
HADLEY WICKHAM: I think
if you want people
to be able to run
your tests, you'd
have to include them
in your package.
Because they are literally
like the correct output.
One thing I did
forget to mention
is that snapshot tests
are not [INAUDIBLE]
will be skipped on
CRAN automatically.
You can opt out of that with
an argument if you want.
Just because if a
snapshot test fails,
it isn't necessarily
true that it's
like a real, meaningful failure.
It might be an incidental
difference or a difference
from a downstream package
which you don't want
to cause a failure on CRAN.
But yes, if you want
people to run your tests
you have to include the
expected result in the package.
JENNY: All right, is it
possible to use snapshot tests
if the function does
not return anything
but rather has a side effect?
HADLEY WICKHAM: So
I mentioned briefly
expect snapshot which captures
the side effects of messages,
warnings, and errors.
If it's making other
changes to the global state,
you would need to make
that kind of explicit.
Like if your function
attaches a package,
you might expect snapshots
like search, which
would capture the search path.
Or maybe if it's creating
files in the directory
you could use--
so it doesn't directly
handle side effects,
apart from messages,
warnings and errors.
But you could easily wrap
up a little function that
captures those side effects
and makes them explicit
and snapshot that.
JENNY: All right, the next
person missed a little bit
about what's going
on with context
but seems that it's deprecated
and thinks that it's
needed when the JUnit reporter.
So how are those two
things going to work out?
HADLEY WICKHAM: I don't--
so let me just
quickly find a package
just so I can explain the
contexts for this change
the context a little more.
OK, so this is just
the per package.
I just searched to find
all the uses of context.
And you can see like
the test-lmap.r contains
what's called a context L map.
The test as-mapper.r, as it
contains a call to context
as _mapper, which is a
little mildly inconsistent.
Or test-win contains
a call to context-win.
test-utils contains a
call to context utils.
So by and large, it's
like a one to one
mapping between what
you put in the context
and the name of the file.
And that is just like, you
don't want that duplication,
because you end up
with inconsistencies.
Or maybe, if I
can find here, you
can see that this is
a test for P mapper.
It probably used
to be test-pmapper.
We renamed the file and forgot
to update the test context.
And so now there's like this
mismatch between the two.
So that's the reason why
we're getting rid of context,
because it just introduces this
duplication for no real gains.
But the context
is still implicit,
we just take the file
names of the context that
tests the JUnit reporter,
for example, we'll
use will just be map_in, so
it shouldn't change anything
practically with
the JUnit reporter.
JENNY: OK, so this is
a person like me who
uses with mock and local
mock, so if they're
going to be deprecated,
what is the suggested way
to mock functions in
external packages?
I read that the goal of
mocker, package mocker,
is to provide a
drop in replacement,
but it does not
have this feature.
HADLEY WICKHAM: So basically,
the way that with mock works
is truly an abuse of
R, and does something
that I now believe to be
tremendously ill-advised,
and the chances of it stopping
working in a future vision of R
are high.
Because what it does is
so bizarre and horrific.
So basically you have
to use another approach.
So both the mocker
and mockery packages
provide slightly
different techniques.
Unfortunately, you just have
to you have to use those.
I'm just so concerned that
the way that with mock works
is not good, and it's
surprising that it hasn't
caused any problems to date.
So unfortunately,
it's something that
is really nice and really
useful but is achieved
and the really,
really horrible way.
JENNY: Does snapshot have a
limit on the size of the data,
and can you combine snapshot
tests with more explicit tests
of the snapshot?
HADLEY WICKHAM: Yeah, so
there's no limit on the size.
And I think, generally, you
will mingle snapshot testing
with regular testing.
Like where you can,
like this was a list,
you might want to test that
his is a specific value.
And there's another
component of the list
that's just a big blob that
you don't want to type out.
So I really imagine that you
would want to mingle those
as much as possible.
I think it will be tempting
to overuse snapshot testing
just because it's so
convenient, because you
don't have to write the right
hand side of expect equal.
You don't have to make clear in
your head exactly what you're
expecting, but I think if you
do that, if you use snapshotting
too much, you'll find your
tests are a little bit
fragile and kind of break more
often than you'd otherwise
like, and that will push
you, naturally, back
towards the finer grains
unit testing that you're
used to in testthat.
Of course, putting really
large files in your package
is going to be annoying
for other reasons.
So I don't think you want to put
megabytes of data using this,
but certainly like kilobytes
of data, which would be a pain
to put in a test file.
It's a really nice, sweet
spot for snapshot testing.
JENNY: OK, I have
two questions that
are a little bit
of emoji push-back.
Not to be a killjoy, but
praise seems unnecessary.
Why not include it as
a suggested package?
And then also, is there a way
to suppress emojis or build
pipelines that may
not support them?
HADLEY WICKHAM: So
some people really--
so first of all, it doesn't
use the praise package.
It just uses its own.
I guess it does, is that right?
Let me refresh my memory.
I guess it does use the
praise package which
is a tiny package, so
I guess we could make
this a suggested package, but it
just seems like, I don't know.
If someone did a pull
request that made praise
into a suggested package rather
than a dependent package,
I'd consider it.
But I don't think it
practically really reduces
the cost of installing testthat
that in a practical way.
If you don't want emojis, you
can't turn the emojis off,
or they will be
automatically turned off
if you're not in a UTF 8 locale
which is normally on Windows.
But you can-- test, report--
I can't remember,
what's it called?
Progress report.
If you really
don't like them you
can turn them off by setting
stuff up in a special way
and and saying show
praise equals false.
But the praise only
shows up in reporters
that are used interactively.
It never shows up
in reporters that
are used in R commands check
or other continuous integration
context.
So I it's purely
just a fun thing,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with introducing
a little fun and joy
into unit testing,
and by and large,
people really like it.
But if you don't,
you can turn it off.
JENNY: OK, I've been
using a Waldo a bit.
Is there any planned way to
control the amount of output
that is shown?
HADLEY WICKHAM: Yes.
So someone actually just
had a poll request for Waldo
so that you can choose to
print any number of changes.
By default, Waldo
doesn't show-- it
shows like 10 changes
with the assumption
that if you have
more than 10 changes,
you probably want to start by
fixing the first 10 changes,
and that will
reveal more issues.
I think this is something--
this is just purely
driven by pragmatics.
You don't want failures is
that generate hundreds of lines
of output wind there's
something horrifically
wrong in the first line
that is actionable.
So I don't have a good sense
of where that slider should
be set by default and
how you should slide it
to more or less output
yet, but that's something
that we'll keep thinking
about and iterating on
as we work on this in
reality and our packages.
JENNY: I've picked
two last questions,
one is super tiny then
one's a little bit bigger
and makes a good conclusion.
So the tiny, off
topic question is,
how do you get the git branch
into your prompt in the R
console?
HADLEY WICKHAM: So if you're
wondering what this thing was,
this is the name of
my active git branch,
and that is some
code on my R profile
that uses [INAUDIBLE]
prompt package.
Just pop the git branch--
and then this
automatically updates
whenever you run in the
archive, so it automatically
stays up to date as
you change the branch.
JENNY: OK, so the
last question, I
think it's a good
one to close on.
Is to think about,
what's the long term game
plan with this addition idea?
So this person is like, for
now in the dev version, after I
install it, I have to
change this config entry
and description.
Will this still be
the case indefinitely
when it's not the dev
version but it's the released
version, or at some point will
it default to edition three
and someone might have
to opt into edition two?
HADLEY WICKHAM: I
don't see any way
to change the default additions
from two without breaking
hundreds of CRAN packages.
So I think that implies that
the default version will always
be two.
But what we will do
in the tools that we
use for creating packages,
like in use this,
we will automatically set the
conflict to the latest version.
So when you start
the idea is that when
you start a new package you get
the latest edition of testthat.
When you are working
on an old package,
you have to deliberately
opt into the new version
if you really want it.
I think that offers the
best compromise of packages
that actively develop
and can easily
upgrade without
touching anything
that's not being developed.
Thanks for joining us and
learning about the upcoming
third edition of testthat.
Now is the perfect time
to get feedback on things
you like, things that you hate.
We're listening, and we really
appreciate your feedback.